we just made a red carpet official with
my big brother I guess I love them so
much
I'm in with your boo trying to get away
from that I don't even know how to act
about that like you kept it under wraps
for a long time did you think twice
about bringing it to the show long and
hard about it and I mean it's what my
life is about you know and so right now
we're not hiding anything so why not it
was like those weird split rumors just
floating around you know really the
never was a lot of wine happening I was
at my feelings and we broke up in like
20 minutes we're now we're back forget
that they're stronger than ever
do you see another marriage in the
future I've even thought that far yet I
don't know you know right now we're just
really enjoying each other having an
amazing time getting getting to know
each other
is the divorce finally finalized when
will that thing be done I'm counting
just like you I don't know I mean here
is the thing it's not that you know
Vince is a horrible person I'm just
ready to move on with the next chapter
in the premiere you say we're not
friends but we're making it work for the
kid what is the secret there we want to
make it work and Logan is such an
amazing kid that he deserves to have
amazing hair
what is Logan think of your man they
love each other like two peas in a pod
is so crazy
tamar braxton spill in all the
relationship T at the mid-season
premiere party for Braxton Family Values
last time there was a Braxton Family
Values premiere the Braxtons were not
there she and most of her sisters
skipped out on their first premiere
party back in August as the family
worked through some issues calm down
we've worked through some drama work
through some of Yan WA how do we get
through all that to be here tonight
together it's the only way I'm just
really glad everybody's in a better
place
I am excited about our new ventures and
the new relationship
I mean look we've been together for a
long time and that's you know expected
with any type of resolution so we're
back better than what was the key to
getting everybody back on board
everybody had to go back to the base
you know like remember why we signed up
for this in the first place it was a lot
of things that was like for Duke
overproduce and over done and that I was
definitely not involved because it was
all about saying Martin Kaymer right now
this one down to another and I'll have
time for that cuz that's how I really
what I do I'll say my feet so we keep it
moving there's our friendship today
[Music]